from screen junkies studios in the heart
of los angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host andy signor
hello screen junkies and welcome to
another episode of movie fights i'm so
excited to have shmoe versus schmoe
profiler versus profile this is going to
be an epic round of movie fights before
we get to them i want to tease what's
coming up on today's episode we have
reactions to the pixels trailer uh adam
sandler peter dinklage uh kevin james
what do we think of that we also are
going to put together a marvel character
versus a star wars character since
disney owns them what would we want to
see if we could have anything we wanted
also what movies shouldn't be remade so
many fun topics that we have coming up
if you don't like a topic and you're
watching on youtube don't leave just
skip ahead bottom right corner pick your
fight you can then zoom onto another
battle or go and re-listen to one you
liked the best tell me i was wrong uh
plenty of options so stay tuned please
also i wanted to also thank everyone so
much for subscribing to us on itunes if
you haven't already we have a new link
in the description on youtube below
please go subscribe to our new feed we
were number one on filming tv thanks to
you that was so awesome i thank you very
much uh we'd love to keep going there so
please uh support us by commenting
subscribing rating if you haven't done
it yet do yourself a favor and go do
that um also uh i want to oh that's it
that's all about housekeeping i want to
introduce our gladiators but before i do
that let's cue the clip
today's fighters are christian harloff
host of the schmo snow movie show zero
wins
scott mans access hollywood film critic
first time fighter
wow wow epic that's so awesome now you
guys are going on uh before well i'll
explain monday many a second let me just
walk through each of you alicia thanks
for coming back you were so close to
taking the title thanks for having me
back i know dan i'll get you one day but
it's so much fun doing the show i'm a
bit terrified though because these two
are formidable opponents they're also my
buddies you know it's like we're pitting
family that's why we did it that's why
you did it you're cruel you are cruel we
knew this would be a fun personal
bracket all right christian but welcome
back that's good we got to get a win up
there buddy well last time i was here we
did like the special the special tag
team with jeremy it was a lot of fun
kind of a mess that was fun it was like
it was like the the it was like a
pay-per-view fun you kind of threw us
all for a loop when you teamed up with
them yeah you know things happened
people either loved it or hated it i
loved it yeah i want to see i want to go
this this back and forth because i do
know these guys really well
and even though they're profilers mance
is also schmoe so it's nice to have a
three
brackets
movie man
i'm so glad to get here people on
twitter we wanted to get you you're here
you're excited to be here i have been
wanting to get on the show for the
longest time but i'm an underdog here
you know you guys have done the show
before i'm a newbie but i'm pumped i had
my triple granddaddy not fat mocha this
morning i'm wearing a star trek shirt
you're bringing this star wars shirt
yeah and she's got an alien shirt oh my
god we're fighting already this is great
and i got a shawshank shirt yeah
completely out of the all right and on
the couch you know him and love him it's
dan murrell
now dan uh in order to take you let's
explain this bracket shall we i hope i
think we have the graphic here to
explain do we have uh the br we do have
a movie bracket uh for monday mania the
way this works is last uh episode roger
barr b aaron and jason to go on to the
first round the winner of today will
finish the third seat and those people
will take on nick mundy the winner of
that battle goes against the champion
for the title belt round of movie fights
champion to see who takes it everyone
follows it so a lot of a lot is on the
line here a lot of this on the line
makes me even more nervous but that's
okay so don't screw up this is important
nick takes this very seriously all right
and the great words uh wait well you all
know how i do this right since you're
new i want to make sure i've explained
the rules i'm looking at the best
argument so make sure you're listening i
want you to pitch your best things but
make sure you all are giving me the best
argument taking down the other two
options everyone understand any
questions
we are on for the fights in the great
words of ron burgundy and so many others
now let's do this this is where we fight
right
fight
round one
the trailer for the new adam sandler
film pixels came out based on that viral
video way back where the the video game
characters came and attacked they've
managed to make a feature-length movie
about it we saw finally our first taste
of it uh so for fight one luke ridgeway
on twitter asked us does the trailer for
the new adam sandler movie pixels excite
you um so did the trailer excite you
were excited for this movie based on the
trailer and we were gonna start with you
alicia
it did not oh the trailer did the exact
opposite to what it was supposed to do i
was excited by the concept i thought it
sounded cool the aliens sending out it's
like turning our nostalgic love for
these games against us turning our
childhood against us that sounds awesome
the trailer started out pretty cool it's
got some news footage quite serious i
love when sci-fi movies do that it felt
a bit like independence day had the
shadows going over the buildings
and then i saw adam sandler and the
first thing he says is pokemon is a bad
guy and i thought here we go again
another state the obvious adam sandler
character because that's what he does
that's his humor it's very broad humor
and i know that adam sandler appeals to
a lot of people overseas that's because
slipping on a banana peel is funny in
any language funny he doesn't explain
the subtleties of american society or
anything new or different he just says
exactly what you know he's going to say
and he does exactly what you know he's
going to do and it looks like that is
what's going to happen in pixels also
not excited to see kevin james as the
president of the united states it's a
comedy what hope do we have for us if he
is the president also peter dinklage as
a sidekick no way i want to see him
front and center
it was late on the dinklage yeah the
trailer at least yeah it was too light
on the dink ledge too light on the
dinkling white on the thing and the the
look of the the uh this pac-man and
donkey kong and those characters are
kind of cool but also look like scott
pilgrim versus the world but worse and
also it reminded me of wreck-it ralph
but worse so this trailer was viewed
34 million times in 24 hours but having
a look over twitter
most of the comments i saw were bad so
that's why pixels trailer did not excite
me it did not do its job shots fired all
across that round i loved it she did not
hold back christian your thoughts we're
going to be on the same page here
because no it wasn't excited for it all
because the reason why when the when the
movie's premise was
announced like everybody else who
watched the trailers this sounds cool i
mean and i don't care what had happened
so far with adam sandler and his pet
grown ups too and all those movies
because this was a promising maybe he's
getting away from that stuff and we're
going to get into the nostalgia and play
towards the pac-man and dunk young and
our generation because that's what adam
sandler is i'm like okay great maybe
he's now going to step it up a bit and
go the independence throughout go the
scott pilgrim round and then when you
see it it's the same kind of jokes at
and it the trailer progresses into
mediocrity like when you get to that end
with that that bit with the
don't worry here's my son you know
what's gonna happen it's gonna be
pac-man biting guy's arm there's no
laugh and i think the thing with peter
dinklage is they're gonna try to kind of
mimic him off of um who
son of kong was based off of the the
meaning of yeah the king kong and and
when you
the mullet is great but like you guys
said you don't focus enough on one of
the guys you're going there for when
that when his casting when peter
dinklage's casting came out
that's what everyone was buzzing about
where's dinklers where's english and you
don't see it it turns into another with
the teaming of james and sandler it now
becomes another sandler and james movie
as opposed to a fun premise movie and
this is what sandler's been doing
recently so adam sandler has the acting
acting chops you've seen it in men women
and children you know that movie wasn't
great you've seen it in punch drunk love
you've seen it now i'm not telling you
that this needs to be an oscar contender
but this movie could be a movie that
both has heart and a fun premise even
like jumanji was a movie that even
though you had robin williams there's a
heart mixed with a lot of fun and a fun
premise that could have been this movie
and i think your scott pilgrim
reference was the best i have to have a
to have a edgar wright type person
directing this movie it just seems like
another sandler vehicle to me
i i saw a lot of uh you were you didn't
seem to like their arguments what do you
usually
agree with their arguments both of them
because i think pixels looks like
fun now full disclosure if my hair was
not enough of an indication i'm a little
bit older than you guys so i remember
playing these video games i play pac-man
miss pac-man asteroids donkey kong
centipede zaxxon dig dug uh that's what
i went to arcades for so seeing these
video games come to life like that i
really got a big smile on my face now
adam's chandler is at a crossroads
because he can't keep doing the stupid
companies anymore i mean grown-ups and
grown-ups too while they made 500
million dollars worldwide combined you
were right men women and children his
staffs at serious movies don't fare as
well that movie didn't even make a
million dollars but
when i saw the trailer for pixels yes i
thought of wreck-it ralph and i also
thought okay and this is what won me
over i captured this the spirit to me
of the lego movie the lego movie when i
first saw that trailer i know you're
giving me that dirty look i know i see
that dirty look and it's not because i'm
wearing a star trek shirt you're wearing
a star wars shirt i'm not psyching you
out good because you could do it
he's letting you talk for one here's the
cell
here's the sell on this guys okay when i
saw the trailer for the lego movie i
went you've got to be kidding me a movie
based on building blocks this movie is
going to suck big time and what was it
it was brilliant it was inventive it was
wonderful it was for men women and
children parents and their kids and it
should have been nominated for best
animated feature in fact it should have
won that's not the argument here i know
i'm digressing it's on track my point
that i'm bringing back to pixels is you
never know this movie could be a lot
better than both of you are thinking and
i'm giving it the benefit of doubt
because it looks like fun and it looks
inventive and i love these 80s video
games and i think that adam sandler
needs to do a movie like this to
reinvent his career and it sold me i'm
pumped for pixels great so now let's say
now we're all for game he says it looks
like fun well that's really the heart of
it we can't guess what it is we can
guess and what we've seen so based on
what we've seen doesn't look fun yeah no
not for what it
everything everything he said just kind
of
had argument it it seems like fun the
premise sounds like fun it's the
delivery of the trailer that is not fun
because yeah the stuff seeing pac-man
like lisa said that's fun but it's the
humor and he's bringing up lego this
movie doesn't have lord miller
lord miller is why that movie's so good
this movie has the same team that
brought you a lot of the same team that
brought you grown-ups grown-ups too
those movies so that's where you go who
is directing it i thought chris columbus
right it's columbus is directing it but
you still have everyone so it's a new
big guy it's a new yeah but he also he's
he's uh columbus has had some they took
columbus off of harry potter because
they went no no the first one was i
don't know if he's gonna be able to
carry the first two harry potters no he
didn't do this
he did the yeah once and then he was not
in his head but once he left once he
left that's when the series went into
another direction when he brought in
corona but that's a different argument
what we're talking about here is as far
as you're bringing up fun and lego movie
this is not lego movies it's not even
close to him because when you saw the of
lego
not
available
humor and it was very clever in the way
that it did it this trailer there's one
that's like oh it's just a barrel about
donkey kong and then oh barrels don't
hurt oh yes it does right it's not
clever humor predictable humor it's
predictable humor and it gave away what
i imagined to be one of the biggest
jokes in the film which is the inventor
of pac-man coming in and then pac-man
turning against his creator but that's
just the fun fact the uh the voice of
the the creator his last line was adr by
our own john bailey shout out to john
bailey the the kill that monstrosity was
john bailey that's awesome yeah the
point i'm trying to make here is that
you can only tell so much by a trailer
that the trailer won me over i thought
it had potential hopefully there's going
to be a lot to this movie that will
speak to both adults and kids that
hopefully there will be levels to it you
can't just appeal to kids with a movie
about 80s video games because guess what
they don't know these 80s video games
yeah they did not play them that's what
i'm thinking why who does this film yeah
that's exactly right it's not appealing
to the 80s generation
in the 80s i played plaque pacman and i
played donkey kong and i was born in the
60s the late 60s does it appeal to your
generation it does appeal to my
generation and not the kids and not my
generation that's because the movie
goers
that is because
hang on okay i've still got final
thoughts yes final thought here no one
expected the lego movie to be as great
as it was i didn't see anything you're
going right to that but you're going
back to because
let me finish
the lake
let me make my own rulings lego movie is
a perfect example of a film that defied
expectations based on the trailer i
think that potential is clear for pixels
as well it looks clever it looks
inventive the joke's okay maybe the
jokes in the trailer could have been
better to sell the movie i'm with you on
that but i still it still won me over
i'm excited enough to see it i'm giving
it the benefit of the doubt because i
see a lot of potential on what i saw i
would normally have you guys give a
final argument but you don't need to
because you guys are going to both win
because you both gave great arguments
i'm not going to team you up i'm just
giving you each a point i think you just
rely too much on the lego movie in your
argument and i think they had a little
bit more i was loud i played a little
bit more of a uh but that was right
you're a first-timer first round you
know
it was a good argument you did really
good they were there but they were
hitting you hard so i'm giving you both
points basically pull off the cocaine i
don't think it's fair do not make me
pull out the cocaine docking all right
so alicia and christian are both on the
board uh round two you'll get there
speaking of movie trailers we've seen a
lot of people on our youtube comments
complaining that movie trailers reveal
too much we've talked about this a
little bit even last uh last round uh
which movie so that brings us to fight
two which movie trailer revealed too
much of the movie let's go back remember
our trailers and then when you watch
them we'll be like damn it they really
showed it all in the trailer uh which of
those uh trailers bugged you the most
and we'll start with you christian now
even though i love this movie and it's
one of my favorite marvel movies of all
time the first avengers trailer for me
gave away too much because they showed
so many they showed so many of them that
you already knew you knew the build-up
for this movie was common like you s
when you saw the first initial trailer
i'm all standing around and and you had
iron man and thor and cap you had them
all there you're like i'm in if you're a
marvel fan you were the buzz and there
was it was tracking well to do
phenomenal numbers before the last three
trailers even came out and then they
show all the scenes at the end with new
york and the one scene that gets me and
is
when hulk saves iron man you show that
pivotal moment when stark is falling at
the very end of it now look the argument
against that could be well that's just
an action scene that's just an action
scene that doesn't have a lot of impact
on the movie and it certainly does
because it's an emotional moment that
when iron man is he he's he's the first
time tony stark is really getting away
from being selfish and he's saving he's
saving the universe
and he's falling and you see the hulk
save him when i saw that in the theater
i went okay here's the part where hulk
saves him because i haven't seen that
yet and there's just all these moments
that i knew were coming in the avengers
that i didn't need to see as a fan
because i was i was there to watch the
avengers fight and so every moment that
i had seen in the trailer and i saw it
coming it took away from a little bit
even when banner turns
turns away and becomes the hulk there's
just too much of it that being said i
love the film i just think that i might
have liked it just a little bit more had
i not seen some of those pivotal moments
mance
my trailer i'll never forget this i mean
it's a little bit older than avengers
but when i saw the trailer for castaway
with tom hanks okay this movie came out
on december 22 2000 plays chuck noland
federal express guy who is stuck on a
deserted island so the trailer sets up
how he lives his life by the clock he
gets in this horrible plane crash he
survives he ends up on an island alone
he has to fend for himself souls where
that is where i mean
that is where the trailer should have
ended but what does it do what does this
trailer do it shows him getting off the
island it shows him back in civilization
where
what's the surprise when you see this
movie what's left there is nowhere else
to go and as a result there was nothing
there was nothing surprising about this
film showing tom hanks get off the
island and cast away in the trailer you
should have wondered you should have
gone into this movie thinking what if he
never makes it off the movie should not
have even hinted that he was going to
make it off the island now the robert
zemeckis who directed that film he also
directed flight with denzel washington
that was a perfect example of a trailer
that not that did not give away too much
because when i saw a flight and i'm just
keeping it on that on robert zemeckis i
had no idea that the movie was about a
raging alcoholic because the trailer did
not show too much same director so it's
a fair comparison but castaway they
never should have showed him getting off
the island good news alicia where do you
stand well trailer noisy yeah a trailer
that showed too much it pretty much
showed the entire story and it
definitely ruined the huge twist was the
trailer for 2006 children of men oh yeah
by alfonso quran the great dystopian
thriller so the trailer starts out with
clive owen's voice and he sets up the
world that there's no hope for the world
because there's no more women getting
pregnant no more babies getting made
then it spoils pretty much everything so
firstly it spoils the big shock moment
when clive owens character leaves the
coffee shop and then it explodes after
him which should have been a great
moment that had you jumping out of the
edge of your seat but if you've seen the
trailer you know exactly what's coming
then it spoils the kidnapping scene when
julianne moore's character takes clive
owens character and says that he has an
important mission then the biggest thing
of all
it spoils the fact that there is one
pregnant woman left in the world and
it's up to clive owen to save her that
should have been the big surprise twist
after seeing this trailer the first act
was ruined for me because i knew exactly
what was going to come it's not to say i
didn't like the film i did but i just
knew what was coming and it also spoiled
the relationship between julian moore's
character and clive owens character it
shows you the photo you know that they
had a kid and then it goes on to show
glimpses of all the climactic moments
for the rest of the film including the
boat scene at the end so if you've seen
the trailer you know what's going to
happen this trailer is pretty much just
exposition scenes it's all the
characters explaining their role and
what clive owen had to do all edited
together and it's really lazy it could
have been a really exciting trailer that
didn't give away much but instead it
gave away the whole plot
fight oh the reason the reason that i
would say that i mean these
i understand where you guys are coming
from but the difference is both your
movies when they came out didn't have
youtube didn't have uh the rewatch
ability to where everybody's forwarding
around you keep seeing it over and over
again now the points are that you made
it to where you you something that casts
away we had 2006.
the trail the trailers and the traffic
the trailers were not as popular
that's fine you can empty will you check
that out the way the way that they are
but watch even those particular ones
that they mentioned did not have the
rewatch ability as say the avengers did
let's say that that in 2006 they were
going around as much did not have the
the kind of the the anticipation that
avengers did so to show all those in
that blockbuster but to go to your point
on on castaway
castaway to me had to show a lot of that
because first of all for for zemeckis
for zemeckis what he was doing on that
movie he wanted to show that you're not
going to kill off tom hanks one of the
most bankable stars at the time so they
wanted to show what his the guys
struggle at the very end of what he's
going to do because when you go to see
that movie you go to see tom hanks
survive on that island for and for the
amount of time that he's there and you
don't know by the way what exactly is
going to happen how things are retold
and when you see him getting off the
island at the very end what kind of
recollection that is and how that's
playing into the overall story of it and
with children of men that's another one
to where you see children of men you go
for the premise of it i think that when
your points when you go back you see the
movie and watch the trailer again that's
when i think you go what do they show
today because the first time you watch
it i saw the trailer first and as i
watched the movie i was like i know
exactly what's coming yes i remember a
scene where he puts her in a boat okay i
know that was coming
do you think that that ruined the movie
for you overall or did you still love
the movie i i liked the movie but i
think it would have ruined it more
because i knew what was coming and with
the hulk iron man moment it didn't ruin
avengers for me there was still plenty
of twists in there but you're not as
much of a fan of that of that genre
though like for the fans of that genre
when you see the hulk
saving iron man there's no there's no
stress to it anymore there's there's no
stress there was never going to be
stress because you're not going to kill
off iron man all the hulk
exactly first of all when it comes to
the avengers i mean what exactly wasn't
going to be given away in the trailer
for avengers it's the avengers and none
of these characters are going to die
none of them are in any real danger the
whole fight between the hulk and and
iron man or thor whoever was in avengers
was a pointless scene anyway but i
digress children of men is one of the
best movies of all time when i did my
top 10 list of the best movies of the
first decade of the 21st century
children of men was my number one movie
it is an absolute masterpiece it is the
blade runner of the 21st century it
should not have been given away in the
trailer i agree with you that they
spoiled the first act in the trailer for
children of man huge mistake but they
spoiled the second and third act of
castaway by showing him get off the
goddamn island
no you want to know
i'm not saying that they're going to
kill tom hanks but what if he never
makes it off what if they find him on
the island what if he doesn't want to
leave what do you remember
wilson you brought up wilson that's they
don't show a lot of wilson they don't
show the relations rules that's what do
you remember most about castaway there
was him in wilson how that how he was
able to power
him but ish but not in the context
because you're sitting there remember
watching the trail going like oh i mean
i literally sat there watching the trail
for that movie in the summer 2000 during
by the way i saw the trail for that
movie on the day that i saw what lies
beneath which was also written by robert
de mexic uh directed by robert zemeckis
that movie came out on july 21st 2000
that was a friday rain of course it was
a friday i'm like right man with movie
dates and i remember going like
what they shouldn't get out getting off
the island i turned to my buddy i said
why even bother seeing this movie that
was 14 15 years ago and i'm still
thinking the thing about castaway for me
it's not so much how he gets off the
island it's the journey together it's
always nice
the the film takes place on the island
and it's about the struggle it's it's
man against nature and that's what the
the crux of the movie is about but even
though
watching the trailer for children of men
yeah they gave a lot away but i still
was completely floored by the scope of
that film the cinematography you know
the the the the the power of that you
brought up
but that note gives me i want to ask
each of you like did it ruin your movie
as well and which one which one i'm just
trying to based on which one it ruined
the most
do you love the movie children of men i
do but i'll say that the the trailer
gave away
all the plot points not just one big
twist it gave away everything so it
ruined the experience for me cast away
seeing that he got off the island didn't
ruin the experience of the movie because
i was so moved by the journey and that's
the main part of castaway is the island
not the getting off um getting off is
right at the end i love the avengers but
that that moment did bother me and the
fact they're not going to kill the
avengers yeah and of course they're not
going to kill the avengers but the whole
thing is the fact that you knew they
weren't going to necessarily kill han
solo but what happened they had to go in
a journey and start to return to the
jedi so i maybe something could happen
to iron man that that a whole new thing
happens for the next movie the next
couple movies iron man 3 could have
could have benefited from that nes that
what if he got hurt so i didn't know
when that took me out of it the movie
itself yeah i loved it final thought
absolutely cast away the versus these
two versus these two
more than any of the films that they're
talking about
seeing him get out getting off the
island bothered me i mean yes the story
the relationship between tom hanks and
wilson was a great supply i mean who
else could make you feel genuine emotion
for a volleyball for a volleyball than
tom hanks when he loses it wilson wilson
but whatever they didn't show that
moment they didn't show that no they
didn't know they didn't ruin it didn't
ruin it for me because they didn't show
that moment but it's two and a half
minute trailer they're not going to show
all of that but they showed a key point
in making it off the island
get it dan you had some clean up
anything yes make my ruling to answer
your question about christian the online
trailer thing uh neither children of men
nor castaway got
you too well castaway predates youtube
children of men did not have a youtube
officially released trailer when it had
like an apple trailers or something
right but not the weekend possibly but i
mean specifically instead of youtube
which it does they were not marketing
either of those movies cast like 2000
for example the avengers trailer that
he's talking about has 23 million views
on youtube so i would say that that
argument does hold some weight as far as
i saw it in theaters children of maine
trailer
okay uh this is a tough one
the tough tough you both all made all
three of you made fantastic arguments
but i think
uh
two things factored my ultimate ruling
one
i like the burn on the avengers
of course it can't ruin the movie you
know the offenders are going to win yeah
and i also think you made a point i
think yours ruined the ending the most
whereas yours gave a pocket of oh he's
going to get on a boat it doesn't ruin
the ending but when he gets off the
island you are less you're like always
going to get off and it was probably a
marketing ploy to tell the audience
don't worry he's not going to do it
exactly and it does the adventure i feel
like the journey would have been more
emotional if you weren't sure where he's
going to go what you said mance gets the
point boom
you're on the board all right we got to
keep moving that was a longer one than
it should have been round three
all right this week scarface remake was
announced and there's a new flash gordon
was also announced so a lot of remakes
happening um uh oh no sorry the flash
chord was announced a sequel to a 1980s
flash gordon that's right um so anyway
the question being um for round three
what movie do we never want to see a
sequel or remake of so which put put out
the best pitch of the movie that should
never be remade or make a sequel that
doesn't have one already i believe um
and uh scott we're starting with you
okay i'm gonna go with e.t the
extraterrestrial
no botanicus no listen
e.t oh my carlson's gonna hate this but
keep going e.t is a perfect movie
released on june 9 1982 the best month
ever for science fiction here's what
came out in june of 1982 star trek two
the wrathicon poltergeist e.t the thing
and blade runner all in one month junior
1982. i'm digressing here e.t is a
masterpiece it is a fairy tale it is the
perfect movie it ended the way it should
have ended it had suspense it was a
little scary it was just a delightful
wonderful moving
beautiful film every time i see that
movie i cry where does it go e.t goes
home
why does he need to come back there's no
reason for it there's nowhere left to go
there's nowhere there's no okay oh
there's somewhere to go there was a
sequel in the book someone wasn't sure
it'll come up let's hear each
alicia where what's your movie please
hollywood never remake apocalypse now oh
yeah
1979
vietnam war masterpiece by francis ford
coppola now this is a movie that should
not have ever been as good as it as it
ended up being because it had so many
problems production hell delays uh
martin sheen suffering a heart attack
marlon brando showing up overweight and
underprepared at one point copeland to
feed him lines through his earpiece
typhoons destroyed the sets the budget
went overboard the scheduling went out
of control but somehow they crafted this
magnificent war film this film and i
would say the opening scene in saving
private ryan are the moments in the war
films that make me feel like this is
possibly what it might be to be in war
what it might feel like to be involved
in war it's surreal
it's maddening it's horror
it really gets you into that mindset the
madness of it and i just don't think it
can ever be remade because it's such a
piece of movie magic that somehow came
together it's the horror and all three
of these i imagine what's yours uh
christian you can't touch casablanca you
can't touch it because and and they've
talked about it remember when ben
affleck and jennifer lopez were going to
that was
no no they were no they were working on
it they were working on it and hey you
had your point no it's anything e.t so
so the
the fact is when that was going down
people scribed the cried to the heavens
you cannot and not just because of ben
affleck and j.lo because that movie for
the time right
for the world war ii era and everything
that was going on there in casablanca
and the movie star the quintessential
movie star and hopefully bogart and i
know because of movie fights you have to
argue this but you agree with me one
hundred percent being a casablanca fan
because when you have those just think
about some of those lines play it again
all three of these
yeah i don't want any of you well i
could see i could see not a remake as
much as a sequel so could either of you
pitch a decent sequel to the other
person's movie the reason why i could
see a sequel more so to et is because
spielberg is still very much
around can can do can if he has a pitch
for it i want to hear it i want to hear
if steven spielberg said i've got a
great idea for for a second et who's
going to go no if somebody else if like
christopher columbus said i'm doing et2
i'd be like no thanks but if steven
spielberg came out and said he was going
to do it it's the guy who brought it to
have shia labeouf swinging with monkeys
no he made his man
burn that bridge so we're not getting
shielded making a bad argument by saying
that spielberg could could make it get a
sequel and it would be good i didn't say
goodbye
i said i would listen uh temple of doom
i actually liked but crystal skull was
awful but that was lucas more than more
than spielberg gilbert directed that
well but spielberg also wanted frank
daramount's script and lucas said no so
if if i'm telling you that i would
listen to what spielberg said you the
question on the table was would you be
into either one of these sequels and i
said if spielberg said i had a sequel
for e.t i would be interested i'm not
saying would be great i'd say i'd be
interested now apocalypse now is another
movie that
is is very close to being untouchable
but
it's another thing that as far as if a
filmmaker was going to approach it
someone like let's say uh david fincher
down the line i not in the same way the
abilities are completely different it's
true but if someone else was going to
approach that movie to to reflect on
what the vietnam era was like i think
vietnam to me right now straight off of
what the time period was for casablanca
more so i'd rather see any day sequel
yeah okay two things here first of all
apocalypse now is it's one of my
favorite movies of all time it is an
absolute masterpiece i love it it is
such a great i just saw it last week at
the center so why would you rather see a
sequel to that than uh e.t because
because and here's why apocalypse now
the source material
is it's not an original screenplay it's
based on joseph conrad's heart of
darkness so if you took the source
material and updated it to maybe the
iraq war or afghanistan it is possible
to do a very loose it would be very lazy
it would be very loose it would be loose
but to give you an idea as to where a
sequel for e.t was going to go there was
a story they were batting around in the
early 80s which had evil aliens coming
to earth and that et's world would come
to save the humans especially elliot and
his family and you find out in this
story that et's real name is zerek
z-r-e-k that sounds like
something will come up i guarantee
mike carlson is here fighting hold on
i'm helping you okay yes because mike
carlson was here promoting the sequel he
wants her the spin-off he wants to see
and e.t the ride took a lot of those
elements
to where it would have been where it
would have gone to et's homeland and all
this stuff they tried to adapt the story
they tried to update the story and they
failed but that was the 80s we don't
know what happened in 2014 remember a
lot of different writers
hang on there off mr uh luke skywalker
mother effer um
here's what you need to know
trying to remake live long and prosper
buddy um they tried to do a sort of
loose remake of e.t called earth to echo
and that movie sucked it was awful it
was terrible it was such i didn't like
this
it was just such an obvious
kind of feeling
i thought it was great oh this is my
buddy echo he's my buddy oh come on all
right
echo yes watching it's not about earth
echo et2 don't don't bother
but can i let alicia get a point
yes take your time but i would say that
out of these two i i would
prefer
i would hate i would hate to see a
remake or a remake or a sequel sequel
but if i had to choose then i would like
to see a sequel to et i'd like to eat he
come back
with an older she comes home
he comes home elder elliot get the band
back together see drew barrymore now
like i would love to there would just be
a nice moment for a film lover to see
them all come together i don't want it
but if i had to choose but casablanca is
is impossible to remake
uh
but
in in the way that uh i don't know how
i'm gonna i'll give you again it's like
actually because it's one of my favorite
films of all time
but so i'm not helping anything here but
it's so of its time chris brad in there
with jennifer lawrence right oh you're
making my argument see that's the
problem it's all of its time but i i
think they can't argue with it people
don't see it well can anyone argue
against casablanca sadly i think people
don't care enough about casablanca
it's like it's like saying republic it's
like it's like me saying i don't want to
see a remake of citizen kane well of
course you're not going to remember that
that was the question on the table
you're not going to remake it
do we know if a casablanca sequel has
been in the works it's the other
questions
there's a sequel
it's never been serious it's just been a
rumor but they haven't talked about i
might think about zack about it scott is
talking about a nine-page treatment that
was written by steven spielberg and
melissa matheson it's called e.t
nocturnal fears it was a dark dark movie
the aliens were tortured and yes et's
real name was revealed as zerek
and scott i have to say as a fact
checker i am in awe of your name and
date recall but
you said that et's release date was june
9th
i've got it as june 11th 1980 oh it's
off by two days two days
but otherwise kudos do that's a very
impressive yeah okay thank you uh
but i would like to see the continuing
adventures of rick no i think he could
do more i just don't want to see him and
ilse back but who's going to do it back
again
you got george clooney's is
he'll be moderate
he would be a great rick if they were
serious cool
here's where i'm struggling here's this
is a tough one because
it's really tough it's got to be about
the argument but i think
uh
you made a good knock at hers because
you said there's good there's source
material there where you could probably
pull out other things and update it so
that's where i'm struggling with where
so you
good knock on that but i think you both
had a good knock on et where you got i
think everyone
even though it's it's like you don't
really want to see them yeah if
spielberg did it i simply can't kind of
be open it's probably going to be
terrible but you're hopeful right so i
think you guys got a good knock on that
no one's done a good knock on casablanca
yet so i need i'm last chance someone
can take them down and then we'll
reevaluate that last chance okay i would
just say that that i uh rick is such a
compelling character he's one of the
greatest american characters of all time
and i would love to see more of him on
screen well just like apocalypse now
could be updated to to the iraq war to
afghanistan i feel like casablanca could
also be updated to a more modern war
this was world war ii and the movie came
out what 42 yeah i mean that was very
much of its day right 42 casablanca yes
42 yes
um but
it's just like you know him picking
casablanca to not be remade it's such an
easy move to say you can't remake it i
mean how do you remake citizen kane
which came out the year before so you
know going with a classic movie a
defined classic movie like that from
well you each picked classic movies
but apocalypse now 1979 et 1982. these
are people these are movies that more
viewers of screen junkies have actually
seen the question on the table are our
arguments more relevant the question on
the table andy was what remake of sequel
should never be remade so this this
question could be asked in 20 30 years
when when we have the same time that's
being asked now but but no he said the
question on the table is ever so in 20
30 years if they wanted to do that it
would be the same time and they're going
through all the 80s right now remaking
everything they're going to hit they're
going to hit all of the world war ii
error ones and you cannot replace you
can have some great actors play the role
of rick but you're not going to get
humphrey bogart you're not going to then
they're going to try to do here's
looking at you kid and they're going to
try to play it again and you watch
casablanca uh about a year ago
play it play it again sam i watch it
with my wife every year okay actually so
uh here's what i'm doing here's where
i'm stuck because i don't agree i didn't
get to finish my argument
i get it no it's not i understand no
it's here's where i'm stuck i don't i
gotta go off the arguments right yes
and even though i don't think this
person picked the best movie i think he
made the best arguments taking the other
two out so i'm going to give it to scott
that's all i can do that's all i can
face it on that one
he took you two out in a better way
because your movie is the oldest and i
think audiences won't care and i think
the source material jab was a great one
you know that they would care you know
that they would care i would care we all
i don't know
just very quickly uh christian you made
a you actually perpetuated a cultural
misnomer which is that played against
sam has never said in casablanca play
that's not good that's that was
something
i feel better about my decision and
round four yeah and if you are a screen
driver you should always you should
watch casablanca should watch all three
of these movies yes and of course
casablanca and of course e.t i'll be
right here
all right brother fun question here i
want you guys for round four to name an
actor that could take over an existing
franchise and i want you to name the
actor and the franchise okay does that
make sense yeah
great we're starting with you alicia
okay an actor that i keep talking about
as someone to watch someone who i think
is on the brink of being a big star
because he has all the elements needed
is jack o'connell jack o'connell really
impressed me when i saw him in startup
and he played this brutal prisoner
showed that he has the physicality then
i saw him in 71 and he showed his hero
side of things and the fact that you
really felt empathy for his character
this british soldier trying to survive
the night on the mean streets of belfast
and then i saw him in unbroken and that
film wasn't so good but he did the best
he could and again you really had
empathy for his character and he showed
how he could stand up and be a hero so
that's why i think he has all the traits
needed if they had to do it to take over
the jason bourne franchise and be jason
bourne because jason bourne to me is a
really compelling character you feel
empathy for him because he's lost his
memory he doesn't remember who he is you
also know that he's done something bad
he has that darkness underneath and he
can fight he's got kick-ass physicality
so all those traits are the reason why i
think jack o'connell would be perfect if
someone had to take over jason bourne
from matt damon
christian what's yours i'm actually
gonna go with uh the rock in a franchise
i would like to see continue and that's
commando 1985's arnold's commando
because it now a lot of people may not
realize that commando was actually um
it was
85 right yeah with the 1985 and the
sequel to commando was actually die hard
the sequel to commander they were going
to continue the commando franchise and
it became diehard that's because arnold
didn't want to do it um now what the
rock has done so well as the rock's kind
of changed his entire path of career
because when he first came it was
scorpion king he did all he that was
fine it was a silly movie and then he
got locked into that disney contract but
he got himself out and he became the
action star we all thought he was going
to be and he's doing fun action movies
like um
like the fast franchise and even he's
done he's done that movie fast and all
those other movies that he's faster
excuse me faster and he's done he's done
these movies and he's hardcore but i
want to see him get into the hardcore
mixed with fun and that's the rated r
kind of uh stallone rambo action movie
schwarzenegger commando to see him
really kick the ass we want to see the
rock kick ass because the rock's got
that charisma that arnold had and we
haven't really had that big action star
and the rock has been the guy that they
said come on dude do it and he has saved
franchises he's saved gi joe he saved
the the fast uh franchise he's just a
dude that can pull it off and when he
takes out a squadron with one grenade
you believe it and he can hit that one
liner that arnold hit and you believe it
i just want to see him step it up just a
little bit more in the hardcore rated r
and have some fun with it
scott are you ready for this ladies and
gentlemen oh i'm excited
benedict cumberbatch
as james bond
this
could happen and i my spider sense is
tingling ladies and gentlemen i think it
will happen daniel craig he's about to
do his fourth movie filming it now
spectre and one more film so not into
that maybe one more film uh-oh hang on i
will sell you on this brother june 11th
1982. the extraterrestrial okay here is
the cell benefit cumberbatch he is an
outstanding actor he is an oscar nominee
for the imitation game did you see him
in that tux
at the oscars that was his audition
ladies and gentlemen he's got the deep
voice he had the wisecracking sort of
smartassy stuff too at the oscars
he freaking did brother yes he did so he
could bring a little bit of the roger
moore humor to the sean connery gravity
and the depth and the darkness he's got
the deep voice he's suave he's charming
he is he is great looking and in star
trek into darkness he proved that he can
handle a big action film and he can
fight like the best of them and i see it
now cumberbond
he just lost the ark
yeah what do you guys think of each
other cumberbatch is amazing it's one of
my favorite guys out there right now but
the problem is you know him as sherlock
holmes you need to know him as doctor
strange you're gonna you know him as
khan and he's just got so many
franchises already and he's what's the
rock
what's the rock
but the difference is great thank you
for making that point because the
difference is commando's not a franchise
that a lot of people recognize and it's
an arnold you're taking over from arnold
in this hardcore action film it's not
bond i want to see idris elba's bond i
want to see him go a little different
and i like this smooth but a different
version of bond
for me cumberbatch is the guy you hear
it's like chris pratt everything that's
that's rumored is either cumberbatch or
pratt i love him now as far as jack
o'connell goes i like jack o'connell as
well i want to see him do a franchise
but i don't want to see him do born matt
damon's born the whole reason the last
born didn't work as well with jeremy
renner is because they wanted matt damon
back as jason at the jason bourne
character no they wanted matt damon back
and they went after there's a reason
they're making the next ones because
paul greengrass and matt damon are
coming back to do the bourne movie
because that's who you recognize you
don't need another jason bourne if
you're gonna have him in the bourne
franchise try to do something else that
maybe jeremy renner did because jack
o'connell has that kind of personality
to maybe take that born franchise from a
different character and different point
of view but not as jason bourne we know
who jason but we're not pitching that
the franchise that we want to see back
on screen we're pitching an actor that
would be perfect for the franchise jack
o'connell is poor how do you do the
bourne franchise without born well
that's what i'm saying i think he is
good for the fans
i mean i'm saying that we're not
pitching like i'm not pitching i want to
see a new jason bourne and we're
pitching who would be a great actor to
take over a franchise so i'm saying
playing jason bourne yes that's what i'm
saying if they had to do a jason bourne
i would love to see jack o'connell i
just think he is so what i started with
my argument was i looked at the actors
that i love and ones that deserve a
chance and someone who's fresh
someone is fresh and people don't know a
lot about him he hasn't been in
everything like benedict cumberbatch
hasn't been in everything like the rock
he's someone we don't know a lot about
so then i started thinking what
franchise would he be perfect for and
that's why i went to jason bourne and i
would love to see him in a big action
role the rock i just feel like i i like
him but he is in everything and he's
starting to get a bit of fatigue but i
get that but you're talking about no i
just don't care yeah but you're talking
about i don't care if someone else
playing jason bourne i want to say matt
damon to me is jason bourne like and if
you're going to move
i agree with you jack o'connell should
be known he should be in movies but not
jason bourne give the guy some give a
guy something else to take over if he's
going to do it and put him in a
different type of action franchise or
like i said in the bourne get let him
try to do what jeremy renner did because
i think he has a christmas and he can
kick ass but he's not jason bourne matt
damon is jason i am so sick of seeing
the rock come into another franchise
that i would much rather box office
i would much rather see jack o'connell
reinvent jason bourne that i would want
to see the rock in anything playing
another variation of the rock character
bennett the cumberbatch for years before
he was rumored to play doctor strange
before he was sherlock but i saw a movie
called starter for ten which came out in
february of 2007. that's when it came
out trying to get your job done okay
just look it up and make sure it's a
cyborg
wait when you look up on imdb and when
it says release stay on the task
okay the starter for tank came out
february of 2007 i said oh my god this
guy is great he was also in atonement
small hole i said he's got the look he's
got the sound he's thin he's good
looking he's charming he he's can be a
smart ass he's got the humor and again
he's got the action chops and he's 38
years old i think i love benedict
cumberbatch when he plays these outsider
characters
tortured geniuses he's really good at
that and that's not jason oh he's not
true
i don't need a centric team
is a torture character
did you not see skyfall he's got this
whole back story as to why he is but not
everything but not every bond not not
all the time they switch it up sometimes
too depends on the version of bond for
sure but for me cumberbatch like i said
great actor but is pretty much always
playing the eccentric kind of guy and
aloof and distant but you've got to have
a bit of that that suaveness too he's
got that i don't know he hasn't seen i
haven't seen that yet
i know that women find him sexy but in
that kind of mysterious
different way than you do for bond so i
i i don't know i like humber batch but
and i don't want to see dr strange as
bond i don't want to see you haven't
even seen doctor strange yet but he's
going to be doctor strange for at least
four three four five movies and then i
got to see him as bond
but that's not the argument the argument
here is who would you want to see
reinvent and take over a franchise yeah
that's why that is
i don't if i see him doing strange i
don't want to see him doing bond i don't
want to see that but i haven't seen him
do strange yet i'm not you're going to
for four movies but i'm not sick but you
will come back but you will see what
happened
it hasn't happened but it's going to
it's signed in it's science it's going
to happen yet
so we can't take what's gonna happen we
know what's gonna happen but we might
like it we might not i think well i
think we'll be lucky if we get one more
a fifth james bond movie out of daniel
craig i thought skyfall was the best
bond movie since golfing well here's my
question who do you is there a better
bond
oh yeah i'd love to see your dress elba
he'd be good he's got he's so suave he's
so charming he's still like benedict
cumberbatch over interesting i thought
about idris elba but i just kept going
back to bennett to cumberbatch because
of seeing him in a tux at the oscars i'm
like if i was if i was barbara broccoli
i'd be like dude come over here you got
the job
i think i'm going to make a call i think
the role is more than just can he pull
off a tux
so we shouldn't that's not enough but
again
i think the ultimate decision here i'm
making is based on the arguments again
of what and i think someone took the
other two out uh with their uh arguments
and i think that was christian
and i think uh if that sounds fun it's a
fun movie and it's not as uh beloved as
the other two so it's a way to reinvent
a new franchise and i think the rock
could use a new standalone thing of
themselves so
christian gets a point nick mundy you're
welcome i live
set up some
steve bennett all right round five
speaking of actors which actor would you
like to see come out of retirement for a
small role or cameo
a lot of actors that we love and
you know we love over the years and some
of them aren't showing up i don't want
to rattle them off because you might as
might pick them for yourself but we're
starting with you christian who do you
want to see make a comeback i'm sure
these guys are going to pick some great
ones that i want to hear but i don't
think that anybody
is long overdue for a comeback than gene
hackman you need gene hackman back he
hasn't been around for so long the royal
town of mom's one of the last times i
really remember seeing him and he just
robbed to not get nominated for that
role he's a presence you remember an
unforgiven even i mean even when he was
in a campier version of lex luthor in
the stupid quest for peace was one of
the worst movies of all time who do you
remember in that movie gene hackman
because it's like
breathing some life into that stupid
movie but gene hackman's just a guy he's
one of the best actors of all time i
don't think anybody on this table can
argue that and if he popped up on screen
in a movie that you didn't know he was
coming and he popped in a cameo you'd
all lose your minds because gene hackman
has he's just one of those classic
actors that you don't get as much an
american classic actor that we don't see
all the roles now the newer actors
benedict cumberbatch
tom hardy fast bender well well but guys
like that fassbender tom hardy they're
all they're all these english classic
trained actresses have that that classic
american actor back in gene hackman he's
royalty he's an american royalty and i i
like that i think the most recent work
is those lowe's commercials oh yes hello
so yeah voiceover gene is one of the
best
uh scott what are you who you picked
last move i'm gonna say it was welcome
in the newsport 2004 february 2004 with
uh vermont alright i'm just gonna go
take a coffee
and let's not do my job
absolutely right i just wrote that down
he's amazing oh my god
who's your pick that's gonna be your
next show the movie screen junkies
the winner's right here my actor okay i
like gene hack you're right i would love
to see him but he is retired the last
good movie he made was 2003's the
runaway jury with uh john cusack came
out october of 2012 years ago yeah okay
now my wait this was to work the other
way
who's your pick my pick are you ready
are you ready for this alicia malone
yeah are you ready for this andy are you
ready for this there give it freaking
luke skywalker lover here and cathy kirk
is calling and there was an actor who
needs to make the biggest comeback
is warren beatty
warren beatty has not had a movie since
2001's town and country that movie was a
critical and commercial bomb it was a
disaster there were a lot of problems
that went into making that movie which
is probably why he hasn't made a movie
since the last good movie he made good
movie he made
was bullworth
to 1998
he directed it as well as starred in it
that movie is almost let's see it's 17
years old it's almost 20 years old now
there was a chance back 10 years ago
where there were rumors and it got
pretty far so it's not just a rumor that
warren beatty was going to play bill
and kill bills volume one and two and it
didn't happen how great would that have
been no offense to david carradine but
just the thought of seeing warren beatty
as bill
okay it's 2015 he turns 80 years old on
march 30th double check that brother he
turns 80 years old on march 30th to see
warren beatty
here's where i would love to see warren
beatty dc does a version of the dark
knight where bruce wayne is
is in his golden years and warren beatty
is bruce wayne now there's a comeback
role it wouldn't be a cameo it would no
that would be
a roll warren beatty is bruce wayne
batman come on i mean i
but know would be closer to the spirit
of frank miller's comic than anything
we've seen so far warren beatty will be
aggressive all right before we i know
let's get at least what you pick i can't
believe you guys aren't saying the
biggest one sean connery
we want to see sean connery come out of
retirement and do a small role or a
cameo now he said he's retired he's done
a bit of voice work i believe but his
last film he did was the league of
extraordinary channels which was in 2003
exactly thank you and what a shame to go
out on that note as his last major
acting role now uh michael kane is good
friends with sean connery and he said
that he called him up and and michael
caine says the movie business is what
retired sean connery because all he was
being offered were old man roles and he
didn't want that but how amazing would
it be to see him have a cameo in a jeep
spa movie yes or even in indiana jones
and whatever they do with it apparently
got quite far into uh thinking in
skyfall that the character played by
albert finney kincaid might be sean
connery but then i think sam mendes
decided that that would take people out
of the movie and i agree if in a bond
movie you don't want to see him play a
different character uh you just want to
see him wouldn't it be great if he was
at the bar just drinking a martini and
has a line
that would be such a thrill i miss
seeing him on screen i really really do
and i understand he wants to be retired
from acting just please don't let it go
out on the league of extraordinary
gentlemen that's the problem that's the
problem with all three of these roles i
mean gene hackman went out with welcomed
the mooseport uh warren beatty with town
and country sean connor a league of
extraordinary gentlemen he has no
they're better than that they deserve
all three of these actors i mean i know
i'm going i'm playing i'm going to be a
nice guy right now because i am a nice
guy and that's my biggest problem nice
guys finish last but you can help me
finish first right here let's so here's
no matter what they do no matter what
they do any one of these actors does a
role in a drama even even maybe uh uh if
it's a small role they would get
nominated sight unseen because people
will be so happy it was a cameo would be
just so much fun to see sean connery you
know and he wouldn't need much time but
cameos are fun for sure and
like but the thing with sean connery
he's sick you didn't want to be offered
old man roles the unfortunate part is
uh now the thing with with gene hackman
embraces it willem bryce he's he's just
such a powerful force now i love sean
connery i do the question here is which
one do we want to see come out of
retirement yeah not what are they going
to do that's the dream role here so i
just need you each to sell me she did a
very good job there so just quickly
sell me why you're what's your comeback
that's going to be better than that so
far as well like come back roland even
though you have a shot even though he
did it years ago i'd like to see and we
don't need to this everyone comes back
and wants to do like a superhero movie
with with uh
batman or or the bond thing i'd like to
just see him come back in a dramatic
role gene hackman he played a coach once
before in hoosiers maybe that you know
20 30 years later to play a different
version of the coach talk about a guy
who can can hit an inspirational speech
a guy that can really motivate motivate
you as an audience member watching uh
watching every bit every word that comes
out of his mouth because of the way he
he pronounces it it's a great actor do
you guys think i mean it does has
hackman missed more than connery or
beatty is what i actually don't know
he's definitely missed more than
anything i i still i still think of him
as being around like i i watch royal
tenenbaums all the time and and i forget
that he's not on screen that's how good
but that's how good he is
he he has left a huge chunk behind him i
miss warren beatty if you look back at
the 60s and the 70s he was bruce wayne
he was a playboy he was the most
desirable man
in the country not just in hollywood in
the world and he's been he's been away
he he you know he made an honest woman
out of it benning or she made an honest
woman out of him is more like it because
he was a player but your pitch is still
the moment
you know i think the thing is hanging on
there okay quick quick quick quick i
know but just get it out quick bro
okay real quick warren beatty as bruce
wayne it's perfect got it
but i i listen i just think that these
and i love all these guys the thing is
we're pitching movie stars here and i'm
pitching i want to pitch the actor i
want to pitch the they're all great
actors they are great actors
they're all great actors but i'm saying
the pitch here is you know he's
with annette benning and movies they're
talking about movie stars in hollywood
and famous stuff i'm talking about the
action i'm not listening to the
semantics i'm focusing on the mate one
last thing
is clean up any last thoughts uh just
how amazing would it be to sit in a
theater in a bond film and not have it
not know and then suddenly see him see
sean connery that would make my heart
sing dan final uh clean up here well i
think this is i mean i don't care about
the game
no this is hugely relevant to the
argument is that warren beatty just
finished a movie he wrote and directed
it he's going to be in it he's playing
howard here you're like no that means
and it's coming out [ __ ] this year so
that's the other actor the other two
have no projects in development warren
beatty has something that correct me if
i'm wrong but i don't think and i think
yeah i don't think gene heckman has said
he is retired plus we hear him on those
ads all the time right we hear him lose
that alicia wins yeah
come on you want to see connery i do
want to say
that yeah we can watch him on cnn the
fact that sean connery round six wait
wait wait hang on hold on hold on round
six
let's move through since disney owns
their i want to leave some time for this
this is a fun one it's our crazy big one
so everyone's got to take this seriously
uh since disney owns marvel and star
wars um
swill1092 asked if there was ever a
battle between a star wars character and
a marvel character which two would
create the best fight this is movie
fights this is a dream battle who from
star wars you take who from marvel and
then who do we see versus we're starting
with you scott okay if you're going to
pit
okay first of all you're asking a star
trek guy a star wars question i love
them both but i do love star trek more
but i do love star wars so if you're
going to make the odds even in marvel
versus lucasfilm in in in disney since
disney owned some both i'd say you got
to take iron man okay who in the star
wars universe
wears iron or something like it and an
exoskeleton darth vader so you put iron
man versus darth vader and as long as
you make sure that darth vader cannot
use the force because if you do all bets
are off all bets are off all bets are
off if you lost the argument there
what's alicia got
yeah i mean
why do you take away the four anyway
alicia go ahead okay well
you both know that i am not the biggest
marvel fan i'm not the biggest star wars
fan i don't know as much
about these two franchises as you guys
definitely oh come on don't lose it
right off the bat come on this is what
i'm saying so when i when i watch these
movies i'm not i'm not uh is so into the
action scenes like i'm sure you guys are
so the battle for me that i would love
to see what i love about both these
films are the characters and what i love
about the characters are the dialogue
and and particularly the humor the
brevity so what i'm going for
is not a battle
a fighting battle i'm going for a battle
of wits and i would love to see
han solo with tony stark oh i think
they're just star-lord because both of
them uh oh yeah no i didn't think of
that one both of them i have very
sarcastic wit both of them
i i love i i'd like to be with both of
these guys they're so charming and both
of them have uh you know because they
they're so great because of the actors
playing them they bring out the best
parts of harrison four and the best
parts of robert downey jr and i don't
know who would win if it was just a
dialogue matchup between them but i
would love to see that more than seeing
someone fight because i know we could
get into semantics of the force versus
the superpowers and that's not
interesting to me like the arc i've said
before when i watch superhero films i'm
not that worried during the action
scenes because i know what's going to
come next i know the movies that are
coming next so i know that the
characters are going to survive but
that's just me personally i know people
out there get excited about the action
what i love is seeing the characters up
against each other and i would love to
see these two in the same movie well
then annie can book them on movie fights
because i want to see those guys fight
yeah but that's the question
so for me i want to see and because
we're doing fantasy world here so let's
go super fantasy let's make this a rated
r movie with with marvel vs star wars
let's get tarantino directed and have
mace windu versus nick fury how about
that you have mace windu versus nick
fury in a fight look at those sam
jackson versus sam jackson narrated our
fight because you talk about our
survivor you talk about nick fury nick
fury finds a way to fight and mace windu
was known to be the second most powerful
jedi next to yoda and he is going to use
the force don't you the whole point is
that he's a jedi he's going to use the
force but is how is mace windu going to
survive it is he going to cheat is he
going to use because he's not he's not
an honest guy we've seen him in the
avengers he's pulled some strings don't
listen to the arguments
this argument this is a fight this this
argument i don't listen can we just do
this one again and again
versus darth vader they're both wearing
i'm not you're not using the force and
you would admit you don't like any of
those freaking forces
but i'm a hardcore star wars fan here in
the fact that there's
versus nicknames so easy to do darth
vader they're secondary characters do
the best of the best put the best of the
best against each other the best in
marvel one of the best anyway is iron
man wait a minute
these guys got to
i get it but it has to be fight so you
didn't pick a fight so now it's hard for
me to fight you said you wanted a battle
battle
that'd be fun this question is just
tough and then you did pick just the two
big people but they get to go out the
force okay well put the force back in
okay all pets are off come on all bets
are off okay and then nice wind all
right so tell me again what does mace
win
but listen look but annie look at the
initial i'm listening i'm talking about
we're talking fantasy tarantino
directing this and you have we're not
talking about directors shush now
we're talking about fantasy world in a
rated r world they were going to do a
rated r video game 1313 that got taken
off finally get a rated r version you
have mace windu and uh nick fury and
tarantino's directing it you get the
tarantino dialogue between the two of
those guys we're talking about two
fantasy characters the purple lightsaber
the it's my light saber [ __ ] you
haven't screamed it it would be so
confusing of course it would be a lot of
fun because the dialogue and the and the
fight and the fact that you can get the
avengers you get the avengers too i
don't understand what's happening here
and i don't know enough about these two
these two characters are not the most
compelling characters i just didn't want
to go
all the way you always go vader or you
go yoda you can go chris you can go star
lord so here's where i'm stuck the most
common i'm going to give you guys i want
to wrap this up because let's see maybe
surprise me maybe i'm being unfair but
pitch me quickly the pitch of the movie
why is this movie going to be good and i
need you to use the universes to your
advantage and that's where i'm
struggling you might have trouble but
yeah how do we make it happen star wars
and marvel fans why am i believing it
into this movie
mark
the avengers are the last stand to save
the earth from the empire
and after a big battle the only two left
standing are iron man and darth vader
they are both wearing armor they are the
best known and most beloved characters
in the cinematic universes of marvel and
of star wars you pit them against each
other it's the dream fight it's the
ultimate fight
i went i went away from like the actual
trying to pitch a real movie from
because it's a galaxy far far away and a
long time ago it could never happen so i
went super fun ridiculous anything can
happen in the movies christian you can't
do long but not in timeline a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away it could
never happen
as far as present goes now for me i
wanted to go fun and almost like a fan
film and who would you want to do a fan
film version of it tarantino just the
the fun dialogue to see
what nick is he playing both characters
yeah you could do it in event look andy
circus is playing his play andy circus
can play a lot of different characters
in in the uh performance capture way but
you can maybe change that up in a couple
years we're talking about 10 20 30 years
from now who knows what's gonna happen i
just think it'll be very fun to watch a
guy who's been in both franchises pit up
against each other because of two very
different characters and with two
different philosophies on life and i
think the philosophies on life is what
could really make me imagine you could
go ahead now tell me it's amazing
anybody's game at this point two hours
around a two-hour movie of people
talking
hey that's my jam
star wars star wars versus avengers all
right
okay
imagine a movie with uh directed by john
favreau because john favreau did such a
great thing with the iron man character
he made a non-comic book lover really
love this character and feel for this
character a lot of that had to do with
him a lot of that had to do with rob
downey jr and those two are friends and
they work really well i would love to
see what he would do with han solo i
think that would be so much fun he had
his chance with cowboys and aliens it
didn't work out there both of them both
of them are oh yeah but that was a
different premise but it's still working
yeah yeah this is this is a cowboy in
space this is much cooler
and uh and they're both great pilots and
they both have the great sarcastic wit i
just think they have the charm the wit
and it would be a great battle between
them i just think when it gets down to
semantics it's like the force always
wins and that's what lost me the last
maybe that's why that's why darth vader
would crush iron man in two seconds
talking about a fight
here's my so all right the question was
best fight i'm going to make a ruling
just because this question was kind of
silly
uh but you took away the force so you
did that in the beginning and i don't
remember that well put it back it's fine
you check it out i got it based on what
you did you're just changing because i
told you that that shouldn't change your
argument but you took it out and that
just made it uninteresting because i
wanted to make it level i wanted to make
it even otherwise
so what the fight look look at the fight
in winter soldier what happened the way
that that when when uh nick fury got
away remember that scene in what what
was daniel jackson
why not what it's a different because
you're because you're living in the now
my friend we should win
wins oh my god wow guys do you want to
see that question again with true fans
who put some thought into it
was that just stupid please tell me and
the twitter and the comments because i
don't know i was just going fun i didn't
want to go through something i maybe
think the phone is always going to win
that question
that's why yeah
would be funny to watch them it would be
fun and yours just confused the heck out
of me and you took the force out so
what's going to happen then there was
that that's that was just oh sorry
i like that i didn't think about that
round seven dan's giving me a look he is
so confused what's happening
that's hey sometimes you just you just
cause you're being
i didn't mean to be hard i apologize for
being hard well she admitted she was a
non-fan that's what i was just saying
i'm basing on that you two did make uh
interesting but for a non-fan i did
pretty well you did good all right round
seven our last round here as we try and
wrap this up because i'm always trying
to be tighter and i didn't do it again
damn it uh honest trailer tie in as
usual here in our last question uh this
week's honest trailer uh wraps up a
franchise
trilogy
yeah um and it's uh there's some there's
like five things in it that they sort of
fight right yeah i couldn't i couldn't
pick all the battles yeah yeah i don't
know how many battles there actually
were it's very confusing foreign
so that said um uh it's a final film in
a series that should never been uh uh
that should have never made this many
films we think uh so we're uh uh asking
you guys what's the best final film of a
final series so a series that wrapped up
what was the best finale final chapter
in the movie uh
uh
you know chapters alicia starting with
you i wish this was tequila okay
go with me here i'm ready
the when i was looking at the franchises
most of them haven't ended so i was
thinking about toy story 3 but then i
thought well then another toy story is
coming so as far as a final film that
was definitely a final final that is
that is the end of that trilogy they did
see it the new movie will start a new
right well i was just thinking one that
completely ends that that whole
franchise and there's been no talk of
anything further
twilight breaking dawn part two now it's
a terrible movie i will admit it's a
terrible movie sure you want to go back
to toy story
maybe no let's hear it all right so it's
a terrible film uh the whole franchise i
mean the whole books i read all the
books and it's all about abstinence it's
all about don't have sex because if you
do then you'll have a vampire baby and
you'll die and you have to be reborn as
a vampire but whatever the fans love it
bill condon had a hell of a job to
direct this movie and to make this one
book compelling in two two parts so the
the final one the reason that i like
this final film in the franchise is
because it got crazy and it did exactly
what i really wanted it to do there's
that dream when she gives birth or does
that in the future
so you've got all these elements which
seem ridiculous you've got the the
vampire baby called renesme you've got
the the werewolf that falls in love with
the baby that is super creepy then you
have bella who's a slightly more
interesting character as a vampire but
not much and you've got edward who just
pouts around the place so it's never
going to be a great movie but the thing
that i loved about it was seeing it in a
packed theater with the fans it has to
be one of my favorite experiences ever
because they did this crazy dream thing
at the end where alice has this
premonition and you think it's real and
everyone dies and it is so awesome there
are heads flying everywhere and just to
hear the screams from the fans was one
of the most satisfying experiences i've
had people were screaming
really honestly
yeah i'm dark and disturbed people were
crying people couldn't believe what was
happening and i was going is this really
happening this is awesome and then the
dream ends but i thought for what they
did they took that one sentence in the
book and they made it great so they did
the best that they could with the
franchise and the best part about
twilight breaking dawn part two was that
it ended no more twilight yes they're
talking about it i think yes no all
right good good
uh christian where do you stand i gotta
go with harry potter and deathly hallows
part two because for me
we were talking about it earlier on the
show is that harry potter the
christopher columbus versions even
though you know he was removed for it i
actually enjoyed one or two more than
most people but it started to really
progress al alfonso quran's uh verse
third one that really changed the
direction of it and it got progressively
better and better and better and the
last two and there's this trend now
where everybody's splitting up the last
two movies but harry potter was one that
needed to do it it was it was a large it
was a large book um from for me part one
um i liked part one when you watch it as
a whole so i guess it really ties into
my my argument here is why overall you
got to focus on the movie i know but i'm
saying one one and two the movies one
and two combined together really really
hits as it the the overall lapping story
is one continuous
story two films she picked your picture
part two not part one part two of the
movie concludes everything that led up
until the very end of that film you got
you
harry's arc goes all the way through
from him being this this timid kid who
doesn't understand to really coming into
his own what he is as a wizard to watch
the progression of his friends you have
losses you have sacrifice you find out
all the characters that you do normally
in a really great television show with
snape and the progression of his
character why he did what he did
most most harry potter and movie fans
were satisfied with the ending of that
movie it's why it's one of the most
profitable franchises of all time
because it had a clear-cut beginning it
had a clear-cut end even though they're
doing spin-off films which is fine harry
potter's arc ended the way it should
have and for me that's why it's my my my
favorite uh man what's your pick well
we're we're on a line here a lot of talk
about jason bourne i'm gonna go with the
bourne ultimatum released on
august 3rd 2007 double check my fax here
pal first one came out
identity came out like a new one coming
out there's a yeah there's no ultimatum
let me i have an argument here okay
that's what this is about this is called
movie fights and heroes which
their other names are confusing which
one this is the first one the first one
was born identity came out in june of
2002 the bourne supremacy came out in
july of 2004 and the bourne ultimatum
came out on august 34
what's the new one the new one
oh that's the born legacy
is talked about a lot in that movie but
he is not he's only in it on attention
all right so i haven't started my
argument debatable we let you have it
it's debatable
here's why first of all unlike your
films which are part twos the born
ultimatum stands on its own you do not
need to see the first two films to enjoy
the born ultimatum if you didn't see any
of any of the twilight movies including
breaking dawn part one if you didn't see
deathly hall as part one good luck in
trying to pick up deathly hal's part two
or unfortunately or fortunately i think
you can pick it up
it's but you said it's a terrible movie
and it is but the born ultimatum is the
best of the bunch the first one was a
lot better than people expected it to be
because there were a lot of production
problems and that was directed by doug
lyman then paul greengrass comes in to
the second film brings the whole shaky
camera thing into it and it gives the
movie a sense of urgency and real
visceral thrill and then the third film
the born ultimatum takes it to another
level the story is smart and you're
really getting into what happened in the
third one you find out who he really is
i mean don't forget jason bourne didn't
that what happened in the other two
that's my argument i'm not trying to be
can you help me just remember which one
because they all say whatever
can you just tell me specifically tell
me which one that was this is the one
with brian i'm challenging you because
if you can i will be impressed that the
brian cox comes back and he you know uh
uh jason bourne confronts brian cox on
his real identity okay remember and then
you've got the whole thing with uh with
the the the jumping across the rooftops
and jumping into one apartment and then
on to the next one the action scenes of
that movie were fantastic the shaky
camera the visceral thrill it was pulse
pounding really kept you on the edge
jumped through the window that was
number two
that was a great no that was the third
movie now the magazine though is two
right yes the magazine was two but what
made the made the third movie great was
it stood on its own it stood on its own
and and but if you see the first two
movies born ultimatum ends the way the
first movie started where you see jason
bourne floating in the water you think
he's dead and then he swims away now
here's why even though hang on even
though they have announced that they are
doing another jason bourne film with
matt damon with paul greengrass what
makes this a complete trilogy is that
these are the three movies that were
based on the three books that were
written by robert liplum so whatever
happens beyond that of course universal
sees that born is a franchise and a cash
cow they're going to want to keep it
going just the same way that the
broccolis went past ian fleming's james
bond books to keep those movies going
but you look back well hang on you look
back on dr noah gold the goldfinger you
know from washington with love those are
official because they were based on the
actual works hang on yeah yeah i just
need to have them get some thoughts and
too okay last last thought is again this
is a trilogy this will be seen as the
official trilogy because born four
hasn't been made yet but i don't know i
bet you they package all four of them
yeah
they are they are listen they are going
to package them and the thing is what
you said before this is the we're
talking about the movies not the books
so you made all the author references
that you want we're talking people will
absolutely it's jason bourne it's it's
matt damon it's paul greengrass it's the
fourth movie and when you talk about you
can't walk you can watch the other the
third one and not be lost i love the
bourne trilogy you will be more than
lost
because it ties into all of historians
what did he say his last point was the
fact you find out who he is if you watch
the third one wait a minute he didn't
know who he was because i set that up so
well in the first one and the second one
the progression of his character like i
made with my movie harry's progression
of his character so wait you're saying
you need to see the other ones i think
you need to see i think you sneeze
no i'm not making the argument that you
don't have to see that twice
seriously like what you got what you
have to do for all you have to watch all
of the harry potter movies yeah you have
to watch all of the twilight movies you
have to watch all the movies the
argument is not do you have to watch the
movie the argument is what is the best
ending of it with your movie the
argument you're arguing your thing with
with the battle at the very end i agree
with you best part you said you see it
everyone dies the problem it was
[ __ ] they don't all die and that
that to me ended up come on that
emotional montage
what about the emotional montage and
harry potter at the very end when they
go when they're all older together and
they're holding hands everyone was like
oh they all made it so it to me the old
people make up yeah all of but and it
worked and so and what i loved about
alicia's argument is the the the
admission that this movie is terrible we
know that it's terrible but it's
it's not a great movie it's not a great
ending because you watch you go oh man
oh thank god it's over you don't leave
going oh what a satisfying ending that
was that's harry potter did you guys
think the harry potter finale was
satisfying and then go but i'm just
curious did that end the series well for
you guys yes it did end the series but
the thing that i was reading about this
question was what is the end of a film
series there are more born movies
there's going to be harry potter
spin-offs there are no more twilights
and thank god for that well they're
talking about
they're talking about they're talking
about it but it's not considered like
you guys well 50 sheets of gray was fan
fiction of belle and edwards correct
well it's adapted to
this conversation by the way the movie
that i was going to go with was toy
story 3. yeah i wish one of you would
have picked it yeah i did pick it that
was on my list it was on my list
that was uh deemed because of part four
yeah but yeah but but born made it
but born made it and born made it
because technically toy story 3 is the
end of the film that's right they've
gone on a record saying
foreign will also be its own thing just
like listen if you look at the star trek
film series the trilogy of that films
are star treks two three and four those
stand alone on their own and the third
film of that trilogy star trek four but
are they doing a new trilogy i don't i
don't i'm struggling with we don't know
if it's a tr you're just making
assumptions at the film end but what i'm
arguing is i think legacy did continue
the bournemouth but it did not continue
with matt damon it did not but he's
mentioned he's mentioned throughout it
but it's all different
it's the same organization the same
reason they were talking about tiny ways
i want to i want to get us over i'm
going to try and wrap it up
we're getting into semantics that
shouldn't be the point but i don't the
question is does what was the best final
film of a series you admitted your film
sucks yours is sort of not really
finished
christian gets the point
oh no one collapses
thanks jt
very nice all right wow this is this is
a very good episode can i just say so do
we know what our scores are that's our
right so now
wow uh you just pulled ahead and scott
so it's alicia and christian go to the
final round with three to three scott
you did really well though i have to say
kudos first round you were right up
there and your knowledge of dates was
beyond impressive dan anything you'd
like to add absolutely very quickly
before you jump into the speed round not
to add to the confusion about which born
movie was which but brian cox is not in
the third movie
he's in the first place
and albert finney's in the third movie
all right good i'm glad i did i just
wanted to mention that
we didn't even remember which one is
which
they're great movies good movies but
they all do kind of blend together right
all right speed round now you guys know
how this works
now i'm gonna rattle off a question uh
first answer you if you both say the
same thing i go with whoever said it
first okay if you both say something
else you get a quick second to uh you
know make your argument i've been
working on are we ready
yes yes let's cue the music fast quick
answers
i might ask for some help so listen
carefully
round one
who is hollywood's best robert bradford
uh daddy
oh jr was thinking de niro
i just because i just read it the first
time those are all good choices all
right why redford redfit the sundance
kid he has proved himself as both an
actor and a director he's had a long
history in hollywood and he created
sundance film festival which has had
such a great platform for independent
filmmakers so he's the best redford all
around and he's still got it he's still
charming sexy i think it's your
definition of hollywood because if
you're talking about today's hollywood
and what makes the blockbuster world
makes what makes a box office start down
he clearly is with with the blockbuster
movie he's become iron man fed was in
captain america too he was but he's not
but he's oh is your win
just to clarify are you allowed to jump
in with the other person
oh okay i just want to make sure but i
think i was leaning towards anyway
because it's a longer history versus
iron man that's a tough one
uh is the man all right
best movie starring
jayden smith the potential kid what did
you say to pepe oh okay and karate kid
the reason why i cried that's true
there's not the big deal but the reason
why karate could that movie should have
been a disaster it should have been
horrible no one needs to ever make a
remake of karate kid and they did and
james smith jaden smith's chemistry
throughout that movie somehow
after earth was a fart bomb but what he
did he actually made you care about him
in this role that daniel russo did for
some reason he was really great in that
movie
he wasn't as good as in the pursuit of
happiness you felt for his character he
was the heart of he was poor of course
you're going to feel sorry he was the
the heart of this and having chemistry
with his dad it made the stories feel so
real didn't even know he was in a movie
the moment when he was in the train
station and they locked themselves in
the bathroom and will smith is holding
on to him and the moment when will smith
says to him you can do whatever you want
you know don't believe in people who say
you can't do whatever you want he was
such an emotional part of the movie so
you know what i mean she disappointed
wow
one more and she wins right yes two more
questions you have three more you got to
get all of them christian are we good
here yeah yeah okay these two movies are
playing on cable which should we watch
triple x state of the union or too fast
too furious
who said it furious i think alicia said
it first
has to win oh man
i want to see videotape what's your
videotape
i've been practicing because i sucked so
badly last time but i've been practicing
like coming up with answers quickly that
was a good one that was good that was a
good speed round all right wow fantastic
episode guys
there were some heated and really strong
i loved it thank you guys for taking
this so seriously that was a lot of fun
so strong i apologize if i was getting
frustrated on a marvel topic but hey
i just like partly
part of the movie i apologize for the
audience if i did that anyway fantastic
uh episode thank you guys so much let me
do my wrap ups here um tell us in the
comments below as always or on twitter
what fights you want to see next um i'm
happy to announce that now alicia you've
gone under the bracket yeah taking on
nick mundy
against roger barr
the winner of that will have you might
have one more shot to get that belt uh
so this is wow this is exciting up there
you're close again you're you're you've
gone up against it you were there so you
have an advantage i want that belt
you have a shot at it um fantastic job
guys again please if you're watching on
youtube go subscribe i'm sorry if you're
watching on youtube go subscribe to our
itunes and check out our new podcast
link there we have rss feed we would
love for you to subscribe comment and
all that jazz and always as always in
the youtube comments tell us who you
want to see i want to thank our
panelists alicia malone thank you so
much congratulations anything you'd like
to plug or say hi to yeah make sure you
check out profiles which is a show i do
with mance every week on popcorn talk
next great show great show we just did
an episode on david lynch it was awesome
and at alicia malone alicia malone on
twitter please follow her she is lovely
christian thank you for coming here what
are you uh that was a lot of fun
congratulations
channel if you haven't subscribed
already you better be please go to
subscribe to on on youtube schmoe's no
and we just had the girl uh uh giselle
from uh from kingsman we had her on the
show last night go watch that episode
she's awesome dude it's a lot of fun so
please go subscribe and watch that we'll
watch that interview and mark hamill we
interviewed him too thanks to you thank
you for the shirt yep
dot com you should pick up the shirts
yes
movie man thank you so much for being
here what is your twitter again sir
rob at
and like
my
amazing lovely talented co-host
co-producer on profiles alicia malone
make sure you go to our facebook page
which is profiles with malona mance like
our facebook page so you can keep up to
date on who our next profile is going to
be and also join in and all the the fun
as we debate all these movies i'm also
on access hollywood so catch my reviews
at accesshollywood.com or watch access
hollywood over the weekend you'll see
that and try and stump them on twitter
with
dates i have nothing else if i leave
here with my head down i am impressed
we have a new uh we have a new potential
fact checker to sit in when you're not
there dan oh yeah
uh speaking of fact checking bravo today
at merle dan thank you so much are you
nervous
whoever whoever wins next week i lose
because uh that's three great this is
the competitors plus spencer i this i
don't oh man it's tough it's tough this
is really tough yeah so uh
uh yeah it's gonna be a battle so yeah i
forgot and the spencer slam bracket we
got two brackets they're gonna go up
against you but man that's gonna be
intense
wow thank you everybody for watching
please follow me on twitter at andy
signor on twitter and instagram please
tell us what you thought um and always
keep coming in with those comments
hashtag moviefights to make sure you
tell us what we need to do have a
wonderful weekend and thanks for
watching everybody bye-bye bye
every podcast we put on youtube comes
with this kick-ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast battle royale go
ahead try them all
if you haven't already subscribe to
screen junkies on youtube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on itunes click the logo to download an
audio version